[Música]
escala en París Braulio Moro Bienvenidos
a escala en París un programa semanal de
radiofrance internacional en
colaboración con la televisión flash 24
en español en el que cada semana damos
la palabra a personas del mundo de las
ciencias las artes la cultura la
política la sociedad civil y claro Está
también de los políticos hoy nos
acompaña el presidente del banco
interamericano de desarrollo y la
goldfine que es Ni más ni menos una
institución responsable de aportar
créditos América Latina y la find
bienvenido a este escala en París Muchas
gracias
Un placer tenerlo con nosotros señor
presidente el mundo atraviesa una crisis
múltiple los efectos de la covid que
todavía se dejan sentir los efectos
prolongados de una guerra en Ucrania que
lleva ya más de un año El problema del
cambio climático sin duda alguna la
crisis alimentaria todo eso afecta al
mundo de manera más o menos igual no
obstante en el caso de América Latina
hay elemento central y es que la
desigualdad social no se logra reducir
Cómo explica usted esta situación bueno
en los últimos años
antes de la pandemia
y especialmente durante el período
digamos del boom de commodiálisis hubo
una una mejora en la pobreza y en la
desigualdad pero ya Algunos años y
especialmente después de la pandemia
tuvimos un aumento en la pobreza y
tuvimos también una desigualdad
empeorando como consecuencia de la
inflación más alta de alimentos el
problema de la pandemia con el salud lo
que tenemos que hacer es mejorar la
educación para el empleo y el largo y el
medio plazo pero también la pobreza con
las transferencias condicionales tenemos
que trabajar la informalidad hay muchos
que América Latina porque vemos las
sociedades cada vez más impacientes con
la gestión social sin duda alguna señor
presidente al asumir su cargo usted del
año pasado del banco interamericano de
desarrollo dijo que era necesario
modernizar actualizar la institución Qué
quiso decir con esto Qué medidas está
tomando su presidencia para revitalizar
al banco interamericano de desarrollo
revitalizar en varias dimensiones una en
la efectividad el impacto Tenemos que
tener muy claro que tenemos que cambiar
la vida de las personas el impacto si
tiene más salud si el transporte es
adecuado no lleva mucho tiempo si tienen
conectividad en sus teléfonos y pueden
tener acceso a la tecnologías si si
tienen la salud
bien trabajada Y esa que está en la
pobreza desigualdad que hablamos eso es
un impacto importante del otro lado
estamos hablando de una gestión que va a
promover el diálogo
la conversación los puntos que tenemos
en comunes en la región trabajar la
integración regional es muy importante
para nosotros la integración regional a
este propósito o incluso internacional
usted ha sido invitado por el presidente
francés Emanuel macron para asistir el
próximo 22 y 23 de junio a una Cumbre
que tendrá como objetivo discutir sobre
los nuevos mecanismos de financiamiento
internacional entre otras cosas para
combatir lo que todos sabemos un cambio
climático que sea acelerado y días
después participará usted también en la
Cumbre Unión Europea América Latina la
celac que reunirá a jefes de estado y de
gobierno de la Unión Europea y de
América Latina Qué mensaje Qué
propuestas llevará usted como banco
interamericano de desarrollo a estos dos
eventos
que América Latina es una región muy
importante para las soluciones del
problema climático podemos ser la
solución tenemos mucha energía limpia
tenemos las condiciones iniciales en la
región para ayudar el mundo a este
problema conjunto
El Beat el banco interamericano de
desarrollo ha avanzado mucho en los
últimos años y especialmente ahora en
los instrumentos en Cómo podemos usar
los recursos de una forma eficiente para
traer más recursos no solamente para la
región pero para el clima en el mundo
podría darme un ejemplo preciso por
ejemplo estamos trabajando deudas que se
pueden cambiar para recursos para el
clima deuda que se puede caber para
recursos para la naturaleza y si vos
juntos promovemos el encaje de deuda
para Galápagos que la naturaleza
trabajamos en caso de Barbados que es en
el Caribe pero se puede hacer mucho más
se puede pensar en trabajar la deuda
para la salud o pagas sociales que que
son parte de las metas de desarrollo
globales hasta 2030 entonces se puede
trabajar mucho en usar las deudas que
son altas en los países que salieron de
la pandemia Y estos recursos direccionar
a donde queremos y se necesita mucho más
decíamos avanzar en ese terreno ahora
bien lo comentábamos en un inicio el
banco interamericano de desarrollo es el
principal organismo financiero para un
continente que supera ya los 600
millones de habitantes no obstante usted
al tomar posición de su cargo señaló que
era necesario revisar los créditos que
aporta los apoyos que aporta el banco
interamericano de desarrollo y dio un
ejemplo muy preciso en el 2021 solo el
51% de los créditos que apor banco
fueron calificados como buenos Qué está
pasando Qué hay que ajustar internamente
para ser más eficaces esos recursos que
aporta el banco interamericano de
desarrollo como tenemos o en recursos
limitados y muchas cosas que hacer
Tenemos que concentrarnos en el impacto
en el desarrollo Qué significa eso
nosotros tenemos que no solamente la
cantidad de recursos o dinero que
ponemos pero tenemos que tener muy claro
qué está apostando estos recursos la
efectividad Por ejemplo yo quiero saber
no solamente Cuántos millones se prestó
pero quiero saber si estos billones
están generando más casas Están
generando más acceso a salud están
generando más gente saliendo en la
pobreza tenemos que ir directo al
impacto en el desarrollo eso que estoy
diciendo puede parecer algo muy claro y
muy directo pero en se concentra mucho
en la cantidad de recursos y no al final
en que justamente se ha logrado hay que
continuar amiga en los proyectos y para
eso hay que hacer un cambio general casi
de cultura a donde la cabeza de los
organismos internacionales están
direccionados a la efectividad al
impacto el la promoción de la gente los
recursos humanos cómo hacemos la gestión
todo tiene que estar direccionada a la
gente seguir la trayectoria seguir Cómo
se va aplicando estos créditos Eso es
por el lado de la institución claro
pareciera que también por el lado de los
gobiernos es necesario hacer esto qué
quiero decir hay gobiernos progresistas
hay gobiernos de derecha hay gobiernos
de ultraderecha que se han sucedido en
los últimos 20 años en América Latina el
hecho es que América Latina crece poco
muy poco crece de manera raquítica tanto
es así que en el mismo periodo hacia ha
crecido veces más y esto en un contexto
de aceleración de las revoluciones
tecnológicas
Cómo va a cerrar América Latina esa
brecha que cada vez se vuelve más y más
grande eso es una pregunta muy
importante en el caso específico de la
efectividad del impacto tenemos que
ayudar a los países con
la capacidad técnica nosotros tenemos
recursos de asistencia y ese recurso
tiene que ayudar a capacitar Qué
significa capacitar a entrenar a la
gente A transferir el conocimiento de la
tecnología a los países eso de un lado
el crecimiento y esta brecha que está
pasando ya hace muchas décadas tiene que
tener una solución en varias dimensiones
primero y muy importante educación
educación primaria educación secundaria
y a los más adultos entrenamiento y
proporciona que se absorban en el
mercado de trabajo además Tenemos que
trabajar Lo que Nosotros llamamos
también de la informalidad y aumentar la
productividad tenemos que formalizar
nuestro mercado de trabajo más del 60%
de la población de América Latina sigue
trabajando en el sector informal
Entonces tenemos que ayudar esta
movilización y a veces la tecnología de
la digitalización la identidad digital
esas cosas nos están ayudando a
formalizar también la inclusión
financiera ayuda a formalizar cuando
estás formalizado Puedes incluir mucha
gente por ejemplo en las pensiones
públicas puede sufrir mucha gente en la
protección social Pero también por esa
gente la gente hace más productiva y
ayudar en el crecimiento a reducir esta
brecha entonces educación
y formalidad
productividad también instituciones
ayudar a que las instituciones sean
agencias que sean fuertes de manera que
que tengamos proyectos y planeamiento
que van para Más allá de un gobierno
más largo trans gubernamentales son
cuatro Pilares a los que usted hace
referencia habría que agregar uno que se
que comentábamos en un inicio y es lo
estamos viviendo a diario se ha
acelerado el cambio climático con
consecuencias catastróficas para todo
mundo Pero particularmente esto puede
golpear muy duro América Latina desde el
norte hasta el última parte de chile o
de la Argentina algún ejemplo preciso de
lo que esté proponiendo el banco
interamericano de desarrollo para esos
gobiernos para contrarrestar rápidamente
ese cambio climático que se acelera día
con día qué tenemos que hacer de un lado
tenemos un planeamiento para llegar a
los objetivos de país y tenemos que
tener planes nuestros tonos sus
préstamos ya están alineados con este
plano de llegar a las a las metas de
país de descarbonización pero hay que ir
más allá hay que adaptar a los países a
las a bloques climáticos la resiliencia
que llamamos acá o sea tener las casas
que no vuelan o que no salgan que la
gente no entre en la pobreza si tienen
un huracán tenemos que tener el todo
preparado para el nuevo clínica eso es
la adaptación y finalmente Tenemos que
tener muy claro cuando hay un cuando
pasa algo tenemos recursos de emergencia
para ayudar a los países son fondos de
emergencia entonces mitigación que es
planes de descarbonización y energías
renovables adaptación que remodelar la
infraestructura para que sea más
sostenible y finalmente ayuda a
emergencial para los países en caso de
crisis señor presidente le haré Una
última pregunta porque el tiempo se va
Hace unos días el presidente de Brasil
Lula da Silva avanzó una propuesta de
que era necesario avanzar en mecanismos
compensatorios de comercio interregional
para reemplazar el dólar en América
Latina Sí nosotros no vamos a comentar
propuestas en nacionales individuales
que están lo que le puedo decir que
estamos siempre trabajando
para la integración regionalidad de mala
integración de la región con el resto
del mundo de una forma más eficiente y
de una forma que tengamos más convexo
con todo el mundo y principalmente más
comercio entre la gestión que hay poco
Entonces siempre Trabajamos para
unificar las reglas unificar La
regulación qué es lo que me parece lo
más importante que tenemos regulaciones
que tenemos menos gestiones en
situaciones al fan de gallas más
comercio con todo el mundo Eso me parece
el centro de la gestión digamos ya al
final de esta escala en París
gracias por haber hecho escala en esta
escala en París muy amable por su tiempo
Muchas gracias a usted y a todos a
ustedes les damos una nueva cita aquí la
próxima semana en otra escala empaque
[Música]